[Music]
[Applause]
ross tucker former nfl lineman will join
us a little bit later on but our good
buddy nick wright on loan from first
things first co-host on fox sports 1
joins us on the program you want to go
nfl or you want to go nba start out
um
let's go
talk about your show within nba then nfl
here's
because i have a beef here dan
and i hate to you know what i mean bring
dirty laundry on the show but
how long have i been coming on this show
now three years two and a half years
something like that there abouts yeah
that entire time uh
i have been hosting first things first
yep and first things first has ended at
9 30 every day we've ever done it
and i hate to do this but at some point
a man's got enough pride and is insulted
todd fritz who's the best guest booker
in the world
for the seventh time
seven times when he invited me on the
show
said hey i'd love to have you on the
show here are the times that work and he
keeps offering 9 20. oh boy and i gotta
say it makes me think todd fritz is not
a first thing's first viewer it makes me
think maybe he's not a fan of mine maybe
he doesn't even like me
until finally i'd had enough and i send
him a text back i was like buddy the
show ends at 9 30.
you get you're insulting me you insult
me a little bit a little bit here okay
so that's i mean what are we gonna do
about this do you want me to fire todd
right now
unpaid suspension one week
how about no meat friday for todd today
wow
let him choose let him choose would you
rather have no money for a week or no
meat today
todd
i could use the paycheck with a kid in
college and another one about to go to
college like i should probably okay do
you know that nick wright has another
job i am aware of that and all i can do
is sincerely apologize and it has been
multiple times where he's brought that
to my attention and i went through the
stop signing for
i know i get caught up in my little
world with my notebook and my and then
the phone numbers and names and rolodex
and and i keep forgetting for some
reason that he can't possibly what a
shocker you tell todd something and he
forgets it uh here's the thing
at first i thought he knew
and just thought well let's be honest
where are you gonna get more juice nick
your own show or leave it early and join
you know one of america's leading
broadcasters i thought it was like an
insult like come on will they even know
who's gonna notice it out there
wow and then i realized the guy just
doesn't real doesn't understand the show
ends at 9 30. so at 9 20. i've even
texted him i'm like todd i can do 9 32.
[Laughter]
i can get the zoom ready during our last
commercial break and then just pivot
this way and he's like no we can't do
that how about 9 20. i'm like jesus man
very insensitive by me i have no excuse
todd no meat friday today wow
i didn't expect it to go that far i will
admit what seton the i was just going to
say to nick welcome to life with todd
fritz yeah this is repeatedly asking him
to not do something and then over the
last 15 years him doing it over and over
and over again this is what i guarantee
you within the next month you get an
offer to be on at 9 20. i guarantee it
could happen but now i feel badly now i
feel like we're piling on the guy
and i didn't mean for that to happen oh
you're not the first guest to tell me
nick
you're not the first guest to say this
to me
bill bill murray said this to me many
years ago he goes i'll come on your show
do not have that fritzy guy call me any
more
okay
that's why bill murray went into hiding
because todd todd would reach out and
then bill finally said oh he's a bulldog
he is relentless and that's why i said
he's the best in the business i've done
radio where usually
and now i've never done it on your level
obviously but guest bookers i mean
they're playing quartal during the show
there's a lot going on they're not that
intrigued todd's dedicated he's just
you know the dude from memento evidently
he's gonna have to tattoo things
yeah remind him that nick wright works
till 9 30. eastern first 9 30 a.m
eastern i like how todd expects you to
change nick he's not changing you need
to change your hours on first things
first every once in a while maybe you
can get out of 9 15.
hey uh jenna can i get out at like 9 20.
i'm going to go on the dan patrick's
show can i tell you something true story
and then we can talk sports i apologize
okay the first time he invited me on
it was 9 20 and that i didn't
whatever it was our first time
i was so excited that i was invited on i
was trying to figure out how i could do
it
i was like this is my one shot to go on
there patrick's show
like how can i make it can we can we
tape the final segment ahead of time how
can we make this happen then i just
realized it's just going to be the
regular you know lock nick in 9 20 on
thursday
all right uh let me start with uh the
76ers james harden doc rivers joel
embiid's post game comments i i know we
could talk about the miami heat and
they're advancing but today is about the
sixers
uh where do we start with the uh the
fingers of blame here in philadelphia
well listen harden harden's the same
draft class as steph curry demar derozan
drew holiday
all those guys are
amazing still now also same draft class
is blake griffin blake's done but blake
suffered a bunch of injuries harden
just all of a sudden being bad
is shocking him being bad in the
playoffs is not shocking but him
refusing to shoot is shocking
uh doc
i
mean doc's got a bit of an honesty
problem when he's like when i got here
no one thought we would be you had the
eighth best odds to win the title when
you got you got there a year ago
but here's something that i think will
blow your mind in because maybe we
should be pointing the fingers at
ourselves for believing in the sixers i
i think this will shock you
the philadelphia 76ers have made the
conference finals
once
since dr jay retired
think about that that's the least in
basketball tied with the grizzlies who
didn't exist that whole time
timberwolves who didn't exist that whole
time kings and clippers yeah kings
clippers sad sac franchises and the two
expansion teams and the sixers
that with the the team like the knicks
were this great team of the 70s that
lived off that rep the sixers of this
amazing team late 70s early 80s plus the
wilt years lived off the rep but the
knicks have been way more successful the
last quarter century they've been to two
nba finals in the same time the sixers
have been to one conference finals so i
that maybe we're just overrating them i
don't know i couldn't believe that when
i looked that up this morning but i do
some conference finals i don't
understand
what james harden's
there's no strategy like i can't go this
is why he's doing what he's doing at
this time of the season
and i
is he happy
was he happy with doc rivers
so listen i someone
and i don't want to misquote him and
because i don't remember exactly who it
was i heard someone speculate on
television that hardin was dogging it
to get doc fired so dan tony would come
in
that's
like a wildly
crazy accusation that you're just going
to dog a potential championship run you
got maybe the league in vp
you forced your way out of houston i
understood it the team couldn't compete
anymore first your way out of brooklyn i
understand it carries pain in the ass
fine
be but all to get to philly so i don't
i think that's too much of an accusation
to make with that said i seen there's no
explanation it's one thing to be bad
it's nothing to refuse to shoot
guy wouldn't shoot yeah like literally
wouldn't go down shooting i don't it's
puzzling to me it's puzzling to me if if
you could have one of the three you
could have hardened now
kyrie now russell westbrook now
oh god dude you got to take one
oh god
uh i'll answer that at 9 20.
uh
the answer is kairu yeah i can't believe
it the answer kyrie's the best player
right now of him now he's
i
i i don't really love signing up for all
the rest of it but kyrie at least when
he plays is still fantastic russ
is at this point a net negative and
harden is puzzling harden's first two
games with the sixers he was
unbelievable hardin's
look at go look at what hardin did
the final three games of the celtics
series
uh from last postseason that's 11 months
ago he was like 33 8 and 9
average in the playoffs for that and now
and now
if he got gets 25 points the broadcasts
are like oh a throwback game for james
harden like he's phil mickelson at the
masters a couple years ago like oh a
throwback performance it's 32.
it's baffling
but it sounded like doc rivers was like
all right you want to fire me fire me
i'll get another job he didn't seem too
concerned and didn't take much blame
that they flame out again you blame guy
he doesn't dock
doc isn't it doesn't appear to be a big
look in the mirror guy
he like the and but he's just
that
i understand if the general point what
if i were doc i'd have said this
listen i'd had told you going into this
postseason we were going to lose to the
one seed and in that series we wouldn't
have embiid for two of the games and try
as he might he's clearly not 100 he
could have been out the whole series
like that's what happens i i think doc
should have played that card our best
player on our team
missed a third of the series and was
clearly physically compromised he did
his damnedest but that that was the
difference instead he got real
standoffish you know what i mean and so
i don't know i don't know
we're talking to nick wright first
things first co-host on fox sports one
and his show lasts until 9 30 eastern
monday through friday todd 9 30. yeah
9 30. possibly join us at 9 20. if he's
doing the show tomorrow do you guarantee
that you will not do that again
i will guarantee because i now put it in
bold in my notebook
you must
you must grow facial hair and have a
hairstyle like nick right as a you know
as a tribute to him a shout out can i
make a request sure if he does
he has to start also booking my guests
because you guys crush us on that front
let me be honest yeah well you got to
get you got to get once a week i need a
damn patrick caliber guest on first
things okay all right that seems very
reasonable seems fair
chiefs are the first team in nfl history
to start the season with eight straight
games against teams that had a winning
record in the previous season yeah just
a coincidence there do you think the nfl
has it out for your kansas city chiefs
well no i mean they they only have
i think of their 17 opponents
what like 14 of them had a winning well
no
12 of them i think had a winning record
and then two of the ones that didn't are
the broncos who now russell wilson yeah
you know they they have the texans they
have the jags they have the seahawks
other than that it's just gauntlet of
games yeah i mean
it's just how how it drew this year i
love how the year ends i think the
chiefs will be
the final six games of the year i think
the chiefs are going to win i ain't
gonna be 12 and five enter the playoffs
on six game winning streak red hot
could you see a team not winning the
division in the afc west but winning the
super bowl
yeah for sure absolutely uh
i think the chiefs or the chargers one
of them's not going to win the division
and either can win the super bowl i
don't believe in the broncos what about
the raiders actually
no come on
i am very happy for the raiders that
they are
they went from they got devonte adams
and they're going to go from the third
best team or i guess some would argue
the second best team in the division
last year because they made the playoffs
they're going to be the worst team in
the division no no no
congrats you trade for devante adams and
then you extend wait you think the
raiders will be the worst team
yeah of course
who else would be denver
uh
yeah i mean
i guess maybe you believe in russell
wilson even less than i do i don't
believe in them as a super bowl
contender but i do think they'll win
eight or nine games i don't think the
raiders very good any raiders last year
all smoking mirrors my friend and i
don't trust derek carr who is this
year's bengals
last year's bengals
no i got you um
oh what a great question
so a team
that's got a guy that's hard man
i didn't expect that question i
apologize i'd love to say the dolphins
but i can't because of tua i just can't
um
nobody else in the afc north would be
considered the bengals you know what i
mean like no one's shocked if the ravens
show up
so
would you be shocked if the niners do it
with trey lance
can we go niners
that's probably not an answer no i don't
know i mean they're they don't have an
answer they're still a good team
how about the colts
so i was thinking them i didn't know if
that they would qualify that when i was
doing doing the chief schedule i had the
colt's pencil known as a loss i think
the colts
all they needed was a quarterback that
wasn't going to kneecap them now they
have it yeah i think the cults are
dangerous i like their coach everyone
likes the both lines i don't know if
they have enough receivers but yes i
think the cults are i mean i think the
cults are going to win that division
the does that count i think they're
going to be better than the titans i i'd
be real worried about derek henry like
at some point yeah the where the the
usage has to wear him down even though
he's super human i was also curious
about the cleveland browns and how many
games would be in prime time i think
they have one in week two or week three
against the steelers but
the nfl when you're putting out this
schedule
what do you say to the commissioner or
vice versa without a paper trail to say
hey we want to feature the browns with
desean watson
is he going to be eligible to play are
you going to suspend him i i'm guessing
he's going to be hard to suspend nick if
there's nothing going on right now
oh i thought i'm going the other way i
think nfl might be looking at what
happened to trevor bauer and saying we
need to suspend him a long time
i think that's one of the low key
reasons the browns maybe haven't moved
on from baker
is what if deshawn is suspended for 10
games
oh i agree i agree keeping baker makes
sense but not if baker thinks that they
actually tried to make him look bad
against the steelers i mean that's
that's another layer to this that
baker's just going to say i'm i'm not
going to play for you
you know then you have jacoby brissette
as your backup quarterback to desean
watson but i i'm wondering if if they
suspend him or they wait until there's
some kind of
uh completion to this investigation i
don't know i i think they have to
suspend it
and i don't the
listen i am
i i am a guy you want on your jury
if you have one if you are accused of a
single crime my burden of proof for
reasonable doubt
what i need for reasonable doubt is you
say you didn't do it nah
that's pretty reasonable to believe but
as soon as
multiple people accuse you of the same
thing independently
i'm almost certain you're guilty
so maybe that's unfair but it is
impossible for me to believe that desean
watson is the victim of some grand
multi-state two dozen person conspiracy
so i i think he's going to get suspended
i think he is
i mentioned this to start the show when
we look at the schedule release that we
confuse storylines
with good games
seahawks against the broncos broncos is
a terrible game yes it's it's a great
storyline
but i don't know
the game feels like it's going to be you
know 18 to 11.
well
here's what i do know why would you
intentionally feature drew lock
in anything is is part of your premiere
product that's insane like the now
if if all of a sudden that's where baker
is then that is more intriguing yeah
russell's first game with denver baker
in seattle then it's intriguing but i
totally agree with you this is also a
problem young talk show hosts out there
to take a lesson from you know two
veterans of the industry one of the
greatest to ever do it also dan patrick
so the the
there is a massive difference
between something being
a great moment and a great topic
guy throws a perfect game that's a great
moment it's impossible to talk about you
know what i mean like so this is the
scheduled version of that russ's return
to seattle is a it's the opposite it's a
great topic it's not gonna be a great
moment it's gonna be a three-hour crummy
football
it's a hot take you can hear the fire
department going by
oh yeah yeah i like that i i hire a fire
department to drive up and down behind
me
just for hot water really yes yeah oh
how about that speaking of hot takes i
thought you were going to ask me about
this and i know we're late but i want to
i need to say this am i going to get
like you're going gonna mention the fact
i'm the one person in america who said
the mavs are gonna win this series
they're gonna win this series and also
the fact that devin booker is playing a
dangerous game devin booker and chris
paul mocked luka doncic after game two
little smirks at the press conference oh
we're not worried about luca chris paul
has asked about luke after game one he's
like what about theo pins and they got a
lot of great players devon booker then
does a flop and gets caught on camera
calling it the lucas special yesterday
luca had more points rebounds assists
than those two guys combined they had 13
turnovers he's going to go in their
building on sunday and beat them because
luke is the second best player in
basketball already and all of a sudden
it's like oh boy
sun's going to get back here anytime
soon i don't think so i don't like devin
booker i've turned on him i don't like
the way he's mocking luca
not not good for him and and watch the
video if you haven't seen it dan
late in the game when jay crowder grabs
frankie nilikina throws him into chris
paul like a scheduled flop play they
have and chris starts falling
they got the foul call but kristen
starts grabbing his hand the trainers
look at his hand just like the
basketball gods smited mark is smart for
the flop with four minutes left against
the bucks then all of a sudden he can't
do anything the basketball gods might
have smited chris paul a little flop
late in that game mavs going to the
finals told you two months ago
okay
i just forced you i just forced that
into the show sorry no you did but uh
you know it's kind of hard to compliment
you when you know both hands are patting
yourself on the back i mean
well yeah of course somebody has to
i mean somebody i gotta get credit why
are you so needy why are you so needy
you know it's a good question dan
but i think you know i'm someone
that's you know always been an underdog
always been disrespected
i i you know i come on this show you
guys don't even know what time my show
is
and
i just i try to at times you know remind
america that the only person who was
right about the clippers two years ago
and the only person was right about the
nets back-to-back years is going to be
the only person who called the mavs
going to the finals six weeks ago
it's your buddy nick wright host of the
watch right nick right podcast which you
can subscribe to on itunes and on
youtube i'm gonna bet you dinner
dallas and phoenix you already owe me
dinner so you're gonna it's gonna be two
dinners well
i don't know if i owe you dinner you
chose to pick up the tab when i was
going to and i thought that you should
you know for a legend you're going to
buy it in the respect and you know the
advice i gave you i mean you should do
that
you know what dan i don't say this often
you're right
um
so yeah that's fine how about we do
dinner we will do dinner and and i'll
take phoenix just to be an antagonist
here with you
that's fine we doing any odds any points
are just straight you know straight up
no problem deal i was going to give you
odds
no i don't need what odds do i need it's
either phoenix wins or dallas wins
you could have gotten two dinners could
have been a two to one dinner special
there's many more dinners for me
i you know all of the different max
kellerman wants to buy me dinner now i
mean there's a lot of people out there
calling a lot of people on the streets
in new york
see me and they're like you're the guy
from sports tv and i'm like yeah and
they're like max
that happens to me a lot bro fritzi will
give you a call next week around uh 9
20. i was looking at monday or wednesday
okay all right see you guys thank you
nick that's nick wright first things
first we're back after this